esports has blown up okay
last year's international 2021
tournament the total purse payout
to kids and people playing video games
was 40 million dollars okay that's 20
million
all the kids now here's the thing what
do you think first place got what do you
think first place got out of the 40
million dollars i'm curious because he's
going to show it to you right now in a
minute what do you think first place got
out of the 40 million dollars 10 million
bucks okay go click on first place click
on it
guys so first place make it a little
bigger first place 18 million bucks okay
so so 48 of it yeah so now here's what's
going on with uh at the same time so
there's more people watching the last uh
uh there's a number that they showed
that live stream that more people watch
the championship of esports than the
super bowl okay so so this is now i just
exploded yeah i don't know if it's
brains all over the world this is by the
way this is turning oh by the way the
sponsorships they're getting
multi-million dollar a year sponsorship
is being given to 16 year olds
17 year olds 14 year olds 22 year olds
they're making that kind of money right
now these gamers are right so
this is the challenge the people that
are struggling with this this the most
are parents okay
because parents are sitting and they're
saying dude i grew up in a phase where
you went and played games you and i
played football you want to play
basketball you want to play soccer
football you know whatever the game may
be
that you're doing now my kid's coming
home all he's talking about is
roblox he's talking about league of
legends he's talking about all of these
tournaments that are taking place and
what do i do don't play video games
because that's what we're supposed to do
i grew up in sega genesis i grew up on
super mario brothers i grew up in all
these things you know
all these crazy things that we grow
jackson yeah yeah the street fighter
mortal kombat these were the games
arcade right we shouldn't do that versus
now
they're
they're now
you know looking at this as a
industry this could be their jobs kids
could make video games kids could be
gamers making
a hundred thousand quarter million half
a million a million dollars and that's
their passion that's what they love
what do you say
to
uh parents who worry on how to handle
video games with their kids especially
now that it's no longer just a game that
you're playing it's becoming an industry
do you know it's funny when you said
that about the games when we were kids
because i about maybe six months ago i
was playing fortnight with one of my
gods joe
who was 10 at the time and i said to him
hey joe do you want to see what video
games were like when i was a kid and
he's like yeah
and we played do you remember frogger do
you remember this guys so we played
frogger for like three minutes and he
turned to me and he put his hand on mine
and absolutely sincerely he said johan
i'm so sorry things were so
[Music]
he looked at me like the way if i'd
taken him to like a wooden shack where
he lived in
so i think we're video games like a
black and white tv versus a new hd uh
everything that you
it's totally different so i think with
video games um there's a few i have a
few thoughts um so one is there's loads
of good things about video games right
it gives firstly it gives a lot of
people a lot of pleasure that's a good
thing in itself
secondly it improves hand-eye
coordination there's all sorts of really
great things my view is video games are
a good thing in a balanced diet really
they are so there's no problem i have no
problem go to kfc once a week it's fine
just don't go to kfc three times a day
right in the same way so the chinese
government and i want to stress i do not
support this because the chinese
government is a communist tyranny and
it's awful but the chinese government
has introduced a rule uh saying that
kids are allowed to play video games for
three hours a week right and it's a
strict rule it's enforced um
that seems to me although i wouldn't
want to have a communist tyranny
imposing it i'd want parents to choose
it that seems to me like a perfectly
sensible three hours a day that's fine
three hours a week rather that's fine
obviously most american kids are doing
way more than that the thing i'm worried
about much more
is the context in which they're playing
the video games because like we were
saying
if a child never gets to go outside
right if the kids are sort of imprisoned
and all they've got is the video game
well i'm not surprised they become
obsessed with it right if the children
need to explore their environment right
our children don't get to explore their
environment they don't get to go off on
their own and play in the park and play
in the woods and just do all the normal
things that we did right they they don't
get to do that
so what do they do they become obsessed
with the one form of exploration they're
allowed to do right now being obsessed
with it isn't good a balanced diet is
fine you know going to kfc every now and
then play video games how do you deal
with because you see your kids play
video games yeah only on the weekends
okay so that's that was my question
how do you how do you manage
expectations with them to say all right
guys if you get your stuff done during
the week the weekends you can choose to
do it like choose what you want with
your free time if they choose video
games great if they want to go play
outside how do you deal with your kids
with that oh i mean you know you've
known what we do with the structure with
the kids every day if you want to play
video games or if you want anything the
currency in our house is books right so
after you read 20 pages after you move
your body exercise and then
you can play so
you have to watch a documentary so we've
gone through uh
the men who built america we've gone
through a last dance documentary we've
gone through history of capitalism we're
going right now through
man in the arena with uh what do you
call it
tom brady so 20 minutes doc
exercise moving your body then you get
to play video games but it is their
ultimate reward to say yeah i that's
that's if that's what they want to do
but no the other day they said we wanted
to go to such and such park which i went
there and we were at the park for an
hour they didn't want to play video
games we went to the parks a sick park
and they played with these kids with the
nerf guns and they had a blast what they
did at the park but you know i think
about myself were you a gamer did you
play games or no were you very i was
more the kid that was playing football
in the yeah you already had the sidewalk
yeah so i played fester's quest which if
you
do you remember
if you remember fester's quest
you're either my age or like type in
fester's quest this was my game this is
like a bizarre
not in tune with games
that's the game i played
thank god final fantasy rpg games i was
addicted so you were a gamer i i would
say i was a gamer for two years and then
i went to the army we played the fifa
soccer and then one day i had zero
interest when i got out of the army like
zero and i'm like i have no time for
this so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]